نعم زين قوات الاحتلال في هذه الاثناء
مازالت تقتحم بلده يعبد هذه البلده التي
تقع هنا خلفنا ونحن عند مدخلها والتي تشهد
في هذه الاثناء حاله امنيه معقده نتيجه
لتواجد مكثف
لجنود من قوات المشاد اكثر من 50 جنديا
دخل الى هذه البلده وهم يتحركون بين
الازقه و
المنازل
ويقومون بعمليات تمشيط في البلده وسط
مواجهات قام بها الشبان عبر
القاء قنابل محليه الصنع باتجاه جنود
الاحتلال واثناء مرورهم وذلك في اطار
المواجهات المتواصله عند كل اقتحام تقوم
به قوات الاحتلال لبلده يعبد وهي تقوم
بالاقتحام
عبر المشاه نتيجه لقرب معسكرها معسكر
دوتان العسكري الواقع غرب بلده يعبد والتي
تنطلق منه باتجاه هذه البلده و في محيط
هذا المعسكر يتواجد عدد من الجنود وكذلك
الاليات التابعه لقوات الاحتلال في اطار
هذه المتابعه والمواكب للاقتحام المتواصل
حتى هذه اللحظه ل البلده الاوضاع في هذه
الاثناء حساسه للغا في البلده نتيجه
لخطوره وجود المشاه في احياء واذقه البلده
وهو ما منع ايضا الحركه بشكل كامل في
داخلها وفي الطرقات المؤديه اليها هذا
الاقتحام هو اقتحام متجدد للبلده يجري كل
يوم او يومين على الاكثر منذ ان
قامت قوات الاحتلال بالاعتراف باصابه جندي
في
اطار اطلاق نار تعرض له معسكر دوتان وحاجز
دوتان
خلال الاسبوعين الاخرين وكان هناك عده
عمليات اطلاق نار باتجاه هذا المعسكر كما
عدد من المعسكرات في المنطقه الواقعه
شمالي الضفه الغربيه خلال الاسبوعين
الاخيرين لكن هذه العمليه تحديدا والتي
تبنتها كتيبه جنين كانت قد اسفرت بشكل
رسمي عن اصابه احد الجنود منذ ذلك الحين
تكثفت هذه الاقتحامات باتجاه بلده يعبد
تحديدا فيما في هذا الوقت ايضا تشهد عده
مناطق في الضفه الغربيه لاسما هنا في
شمالها اقتحامات ايضا متزامنه المنطقه
الغربيه لمدينه نابلس تشهد في هذه الاثناء
ايضا اقتحاما من قبل قوات الاحتلال
وتتمركز اليات الاحتلال عند بلده بيت وزن
غربيه نابلس فيما ايضا ايه تشهد بلده
برقين كذلك اقتحام من قبل قوات الاحتلال
وا ايضا تشهد منطقه او تحديدا بورين عفوا
في نابلس اقتحام من قبل قوات الاحتلال
فيما ايضا تشهدوا عده بلدات في المنطقه
الشماليه بما فيها محافظه قلقيليه اقتحاما
كذلك من قبل اليات وقوات الاحتلال في اطار
عمليات للتمشيط والتفتيش المداهمات بهدف
تنفيذ عمليات اعتقال او تفتيش للمنازل وهي
العمليه المتواصله التي تقوم بها قوات
الاحتلال بشكل مكثف منذ السابع من اكتوبر
وحتى اليوم وقد افضت حتى هذه اللحظه الى
تنفيذ اكثر من 4500 حاله اعتقال منذ ذاك
الحين وحتى هذه اللحظه